the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right everyone let's get started so
today's lecture and Wednesdays lecture
we're going to talk about these this
thing called object-oriented programming
and if you haven't programmed before I
think this is a fairly tough concept to
grasp but hopefully with with many many
examples and just by looking at the code
from available F from the lectures
you'll hopefully get the hang of it
quickly so let's talk a little bit about
objects and we've seen objects in Python
so far objects are basically data in
Python so every object that we've seen
has a certain type okay that we know
behind the scenes though every object
has these two additional things one is
some data representation so how Python
represents the object in just behind the
scenes and what are different ways that
you can interact with the object okay so
for example every one of these is a
different object for example this is the
number 1234 it's a specific object that
is of type integer the number 5 is a
different object that's of type integer
and so on we've seen floats we've seen
strings we've seen lists lists and
dictionaries are more complicated object
object types sorry but every object has
a type some sort of way that it's
represented in Python and some ways that
we can interact with them ok so the idea
behind object-oriented programming is
first of all everything in Python is an
object we've said that before and in
this lecture I think we'll really get at
what that means
so we've seen strings integers
dictionaries lists those are all objects
when we did functions we saw that we
could pass as a parameter another
function so functions were also objects
in Python so literally everything in up
in Python is an object so what are the
kinds of things we can do with objects
well once you have a type you can create
a new object that is of some type and
you can create as many
object as you'd like of that particular
type right an integer five an integer
seven those all work in a program once
you have these once you've created these
new objects you can manipulate them so
for a list for example you can append an
item to the end of the list you can
delete an item remove it concatenate two
lists together
so that's ways that you can interact
with objects and the last thing you can
do is you can destroy them so in with
lists we saw explicitly that you can
delete elements from a list or you can
just forget about them by sort of
reassigning a variable to another value
and then at some point Python will will
collect all of these dead objects and
reclaim the memory so let's continue
exploring what objects are so let's say
I have these two separate objects one is
a blue car one is a pink car so objects
are really data abstractions so these
two cars can be created by the same
blueprint okay this is a blueprint for a
car and if an object is the data
abstraction there's two things that this
abstraction is going to capture the
first is some sort of representation
what is going to represent the car what
data represents a car object and the
second is what are ways that we can
interact with the object so if we think
about a car blueprint some general
representation for a car could be the
number of wheels it has the number of
doors it has maybe its length maybe its
height so this is these are all this is
all part of what data represents the car
okay the interface for the car is what
are ways that you can interact with it
so for example you could paint a car
right so you could change its color you
could make you could have the car make a
noise and different cars might make
different noises or you can drive the
car right so these are all ways that you
can interact with a car whereas the
representation are what makes up the car
what abstraction data abstractions make
up the car
let's bring it a little closer to home
by looking at a list so we have this
data type of list right we've worked
with lists before the list with elements
1 2 3 and 4 is a very specific object
that is of type list okay again we think
about it in terms of two things one is
how what is the data representation of a
list so how does behind the scenes how
does Python see lists and the second is
how do you interact with lists so what
are ways that you can manipulate a list
object once it's created so behind the
scenes you have a list L which is going
to be made up of essentially two things
one is going to be the value at specific
index okay so at index 0 it has the
value 1 right because it's the first
element in the list and the second thing
that represents a list is going to be
this second part which is a pointer and
internally this pointer is going to tell
Python where is the memory location in
the computer where you can access the
element and index 1 so that's it's just
essentially going to be a chain going
from one index to the other and at the
next memory location you have the value
at index 1 and then you have another
pointer that takes you to the location
memory where the index 2 is located and
then index 2 you have the value and then
the next pointer and so on and so on
so this is how Python internally
internally represents a list ok how you
manipulate lists we've done this a lot
right you can get you can index into a
list you can add two lists together you
can get the length you can append to the
end of a list you can sort a list
reverse' lists and so many other things
right so these are all ways that you can
interact with the list object as soon as
you've created it so notice both of
these the internal representation and
how you manipulate lists you don't
actually know internally how these are
represented right how did how did how
did whoever wrote the list class decide
to implement a sort we don't know ok you
also weren't aware
of how these lists were represented
internally and you didn't need to know
that that's the beauty of
object-oriented programming and having
these data abstractions the
representations are private of these
objects and they're only known by what
you can find out how it's done but they
only should be known by whoever
implemented them you as someone who uses
this class doesn't really need to know
how a list is represented internally in
order to be able to use it and to write
cool programs with them okay so so just
final motivation here before we start
writing our own types of objects is the
advantages of object-oriented
programming is really that you're able
to bundle this data bundle some internal
representation and some ways to interact
with a program into these packages these
packages with these packages you can
create objects and all of these objects
are going to behave the exact same way
they're going to have the same internal
representation and the same way that you
can interact with them okay and
ultimately this is going to contribute
to the decomposition and abstraction
ideas that we that we talked about when
we talked about functions and that means
that you're going to be able to write
code that's a lot more reusable and a
lot easier to read in the future okay so
just like when we talked about functions
we're going to sort of separate the code
that we talked about today into code
where you implement you implement a data
type and code where you use use an
object that you create okay so remember
when we talked about functions you had
you had you were thinking about it in
terms of writing a function so you had
to worry about the details of how you
implement a function and then you had to
worry about just how to use a function
right so it's sort of the same idea
today so when you're thinking about
implementing your own datatype you do
that with this thing called a class okay
and when you create a class you're
basically going to figure out what name
you want to give your class and you're
going to define some attributes and
attributes are going to be the data
representation and ways that you can
interact with your object so you as the
programmer of this class are going to
decide how you want people to interact
with your object and what this object
what what data this object is going to
take have so for example someone wrote
code that implements a list class and we
don't actually know how that was done
but we can find out so creating the
class is is is implementing implementing
the class and figuring out data
representation and ways to interact with
the class once that's done you can then
use your class and you use the class by
creating new instances of of the class
so when you create a new instance you
essentially create a new object that has
the type the name of your class and you
can create as many objects as you'd like
you can do all the operations that
you've defined on the class so for
example someone wrote the code to
implement list class and then you can
just use the list class like this so you
can create a new list you can get the
length of the list you can append to the
end of the list and so on and so on
okay so let's start defining our own
types okay so now you're going to define
classes you're going to write classes
which are going to define your own types
of objects so for today's lecture we're
going to define we're going to look at
code that's going to be in the context
of a coordinate object okay and a
coordinate object is essentially going
to be an object that's going to define a
point in an XY plane okay so X comma Y
is going to be a coordinate in a 2d
plane so we're going to write code
that's going to allow us to define that
kind of object so the way we do that is
we have to define a class so we have to
tell Python hey I'm defining my own
object type so you do that with this
class keyword so you say class then you
say the name of your type in this case
we're creating a type called coordinate
just like we had type list type string
and so on this is going to be a type
called coordinate and then in
parentheses here you put what the
parents of the class are for today's
lecture the parent of the classes are
going to be this thing called object an
object is the very basic type in Python
it is the most basic type in Python and
it it implements things like being able
to assign variables so really really
basic operations that you can do with
objects okay so your coordinate is
therefore going to be an object in
Python all right so we've told python we
want to define an object so inside the
class definition we're going to put
attributes so what are attributes
attributes are going to be data and
procedures that belong to the class okay
data are going to be the data
representations and procedures are going
to be ways that we can interact with the
object okay the fact that they belong to
the class means that the data and the
procedures that we write are only going
to work with an object of this type okay
if you try to use any of the data or the
procedures with an object of a different
type you're going to get an error
because these objects these this data
and these these attributes sorry will
will belong to this particular class
okay so the data attributes is what is
the object right what is the data that
makes up the object so for our
coordinate example it's going to be the
X and y values for a coordinate we can
decide that can be in so we can decide
that we can let them be floats but it's
going to have one one value for an for
the x coordinate and one value for the y
coordinate so those are data attributes
and procedure attributes are better
known as methods and you can think of a
method as a function except that it's a
function that only were
with this particular type of object so
with a coordinate object in this case
okay so the methods are going to define
how you can interact with the object so
in a list for example we've said that
you can append an item to the end of the
list we can sort of list things like
that so when you when you're defining
methods you're defining ways that people
can interact with your object so for
example for a coordinated object we can
say that we can take the distance
between two coordinate points okay and
that's going to be a way that you can
interact with two coordinate points and
we and just just to be clear these are
going to belong to this class which
means that if you try to use this
distance method on two lists for example
you're going to get an error because
this distance method was only defined to
work with to coordinate type objects all
right so let's carry on and continue
implementing our class so we've written
this first line so far class coordinate
object so now let's define attributes
first thing we're going to define our
data attributes generally you define
data attributes inside this in it and
this is underscore underscore init
underscore underscore and it's a special
method or function in a class and the
special method tells Python when you
when you implement the special method it
tells Python when you first create an
object of this type call this method or
call this function so how do we do that
so let's implement it so you say def
because d f because it's just a function
the name is the special name in it and
we give it some parameters right just
like any other function
these last two parameters are x and y
which are going to represent the x it's
going to represent how you create a
coordinate object so you give it a value
for the exponent and you give it a value
for the y-coordinate this self however
is a little bit trickier so the self is
going to be a parameter when you define
this class that represents a particular
instance of
of the class okay so we're defining this
coordinate object in sort of a general
way right we don't have a specific
instance yet because we haven't created
an object yet but this self is going to
be sort of a placeholder for any sort of
instance when you create the object so
in the definition of the class whenever
you want to refer to attributes that
belong to an instance you have to use
self dot so this dot notation and the
dot is going to say look for a value X
sorry look for a data attribute X that
belongs to this class so for methods
that belong to the class the first
parameter is always going to be self it
could be named anything you want but
really by convention it's always named
self so try to stick to that and then
any other parameters beyond it are going
to be just parameters as you would put
in a normal function okay in this
particular case we're going to choose to
initialize a data a coordinate object by
two values one for the X and 1 for the Y
and inside this init method we're groups
we're going to have two assignments the
first one says the X data attribute of a
coordinate object I'm going to I'm going
to assign it to whatever was passed in
and the Y data attribute for a
particular object is going to be
assigned whatever Y was passed in
questions so far about how to write this
in it yeah question how do you make sure
that x and y are intz or floats so this
is something that you could write in the
specification so the doc string with the
triple quotes so whoever uses the
function uses the class would then know
that if they do something outside the
specification the code might not work as
expected or you could put in a search
statement inside the the definition of
the in it just to sort of force that
force that to to be true great question
yeah question does the X does this self
X and this X have to be the same name
the answer is no and we're going to see
in the class exercise that you can have
it to be different okay great so this
defines our the way that we create an
object so now let's now we have sort of
a nice nice class it's very simple but
we can start actually creating
coordinate objects okay so when you
create a coordinate objects you're
creating instances of the class so this
line here si is equal to coordinate 3 4
is going to call the init method it's
going to call the init method with X is
equal to 3 and Y is equal to 4 I'm just
going to go over here and I wrote this
previously because notice when we're
calling this method when we're creating
an object here we're only giving it two
parameters but in the init method we
have actually three parameters right we
have these three parameters here but
when we're creating an object we only
give it two parameters and that's okay
because implicitly python is going to
say self is going to be this object see
so just by default okay so when you're
creating a coordinate object you're
you're passing it the very all the
variables except for self
so this line here is going to call the
init and it's going to do every line
inside the unit so it's going to create
an X data attribute for see a Y data
attribute for C and it's going to assign
three and four to those respectively
this next line here is origin equals
coordinate zero zero creates another
object okay
it's another coordinate object whose
value of 4x is zero and whose value for
y is zero okay so now we have to
coordinate objects we can access the
data attributes using this dot notation
and we've seen that before right when
we've worked with lists we'd say
something like L dot append right when
we create a list so the same dot
notation can be used with your own
objects in order to access data
attributes so here this is going to
print three because the x value for for
object C is three and the next line
print Origin X is going to print zero
because the x value for the object
origin is zero okay so we've created
we've created a coordinate object we've
defined the init method so we have a way
to create objects when we use the class
and then we can access the data
attributes but that's kind of lame right
because there isn't anything cool we can
do with it there isn't ways to interact
with this object so let's add some
methods okay remember methods are going
to be are going to be procedural
attributes that allow us to interact
with our object okay methods are like
functions except that there's a couple
differences which you'll see in a moment
and when you're when you're calling
methods you're using the dot the dot
operator like L dot append for example
for lists so let's define now let's go
back to defining our coordinate class
and let's define a method for it so so
far we've defined that part their class
coordinate and an init so we have that
so in this slide we're going to add
this method here so this method here is
going to say I'm going to define a
method called distance and I'm going to
pass in two parameters
remember self the first parameter is
always going to be the the instance of
an object that you're going to perform
the operation on so alway pretty much by
convention it's always named self and
this KNN for this particular method I'm
going to give it another parameter and I
can name this whatever I want I'm naming
it other and this is going to represent
the other coordinate object for which I
want to find the distance from myself
okay so here I'm going to just implement
the Euclidean distance formula which is
X you know x1 minus x2 squared plus y1
minus y2 squared and square root of all
that so that's what I'm doing inside
here okay self and other are coordinate
objects inside this method I have to
refer to the X data attributes of each
object if I want to find the difference
between the two x values from them so
that's why I'm doing self dot X here
right if I just did X I would be
accessing just some variable named X in
in a program which actually isn't even
defined right so you always have to
refer when you're talking about when
when you're when you're as we're
thinking about classes you always have
to refer to whose data attribute do you
want to access okay in this case I want
to access the X data attribute of myself
and I want to subtract the X data
attribute of this other coordinate
square that same for Y square that and
then add those and take the square root
of that so notice this method is pretty
much like a function right you have DF
some name it takes in parameters it does
some stuff and then it returns a value
the only difference is the fact that you
have a self here as the first thing and
the fact that you always have to be
conscious about whose data attributes
you're accessing
okay so you have to use the dot notation
in order to decide whose data attributes
you want access so we've defined the
method here distance okay so this is in
the class definition now how do we use
it so let's assume that the the
definition of distance is up here I
didn't include the code but really all
you need to know is what it takes it
takes itself and another so when you
want to use this method to figure out a
distance between two coordinate objects
this is how you do it so the first line
I create one coordinate object second
line I create another coordinate object
right first one is named C the second
one is named zero these are two separate
objects and I'm going to find the
distance and I want to first call it on
one object so I'm going to say C dot so
I'm using the dot notation to call the
method distance on object C so Python
says this object C is of type coordinate
it's going to look up at the class
coordinate that you defined it's going
to find this method called distance and
then it's going to say what parameters
does it take so it takes another
parameter right for the other and then
in the parenthesis I just have to give
it this other parameter an easier way to
see what happens is by looking at what
this line here is equivalent to okay so
this let the third line here print C
distance 0 is equivalent to this one on
the right and this one on the right
essentially says what's the name of the
class dot dot notation what's the method
you want to call and then in parenthesis
you give it all of the variables
including self okay so in this case
you're explicitly telling Python that
self is C and other is 0 right so this
is a little bit easier to understand
like that
but it's a little cumbersome because you
always have to write coordinate dot
coordinate dot coordinate for every data
attribute you might want to access for
every procedural attribute you want
might want to access so it's really so
by convention it's a lot easier to do
the one on the left and as I mentioned
Python implicitly says if you're doing
the one on the left you can call this
method on a particular object and it's
going to look up the type of the object
and it's going to essentially convert
this on the left to the one on the right
ok and this is what you've been using so
far so when you create a list you say L
is equal to one two and then you say L
dot append you know three or whatever so
we've been using this notation on the
left pretty much from from the beginning
class so we have a coordinate class we
can create a coordinate object we can
get the distance between two objects as
you're using the class if you wanted to
use this coordinate class and you were
maybe debugging at some point you know a
lot of you probably use print as a debug
statement right and maybe you want to
print the value of of a coordinate
object so if you create a coordinate
object C is equal to coordinate 3/4
right that's what we've done so far if
you print C you get this sorry you get
this funny message very uninformative
right it basically says well C is an
object of type coordinate at this memory
location in in in the computer which is
not what you wanted at all right maybe
you wanted to know what the values for x
and y were that would be a lot more
informative okay so so by default when
you create an on your own type when you
print the type when you print the object
of that type Python tells you this sort
of information which is not what you
want so what you need to do is you need
to define your own method that tells
Python what to do when you call print on
an object of this type so this is going
to be a special method
just like in it is because it starts and
ends with double underscores and the the
name of the method is underscore
underscore STR underscore underscore and
if you define this method in your class
that tells Python hey when you see a
print statement that's on an object of
type coordinate call this method look
what it does and do everything that's
inside it okay and you can choose
whatever you you can choose to make it
do whatever you want inside your your
definition of STR in this case let's say
when we print a coordinate object we're
going to print it's x and y values
surrounded by angle brackets that seems
reasonable right so then from now on
when you when you print coordinate
objects you're going to see things like
this which is a lot more informative all
right so how do we define this so so far
we've defined all that and the last part
is going to be new okay so we define the
anit and the distance and let's define
this STR so underscore underscore STR
underscore underscore is a method it's
only going to taste take self because
you're just calling print on the object
itself okay there's no other are there's
no other parameters to it STR has to
return a string and in this particular
case we're going to return the string
that's the angle brackets concatenated
with the x-value of the object self x
concatenated with a comma concatenated
with the y value of this particular
instance of an object self dot y and
then concatenated with the angle
brackets so now anytime you have print
on an object of type coordinate you're
going to call this special method STR if
it's implemented in your in your code
any questions
okay so let's try to wrap our hand
around types and classes because we've
seen a lot today okay
let's create a coordinate object assign
it three four as we have been and assign
it to variable C we've implemented the
STR method so when we print C it's going
to print out this nice three comma four
in angle brackets if we print the type
of C this is actually going to give us
class Maine coordinate which tells us
that C is going to be an object that's
of that that's that is sorry C is going
to be an object that is of type class
coordinate if we look at coordinate as a
class if we print what coordinate is
coordinate is a class right so this is
what python tells us if we print
coordinate it's a class named coordinate
and if we print the type of a coordinate
well that's just going to be a type so
class is going to be a type so you're
defining the type of an object okay if
you'd like to figure out the type the if
you'd like to figure out whether a
particular object is an instance of a
particular class you use this special
function called is instance so if you
print is instance C comma coordinate
this is going to print true because C is
an object that is of type coordinate
okay
couple more words on these special
operators so these special operators
allow you to customize your classes
which can add some cool functionality to
them so these special operators are
going to be things like addition
subtraction using the equal equal sign
greater than less than length and so on
and so on
so just like STR if you implement any of
these in your classes this is going to
tell Python so for example if we've
implemented this underscore underscore
add underscore underscore in our in our
class this is going to tell Python when
you use this plus operator between two
objects of type coordinate to call this
method if you have not implemented this
method and you try to add two objects of
type coordinate you're going to get an
error because python doesn't actually
know right off the bat how to add to
coordinate objects right you have to
tell it how to do that and you tell it
how to do that by implementing this
special special method
same with subtract same with equal so if
you want to figure out whether two
objects are equal and when you implement
these methods in your in your own class
you can decide exactly what you want to
do so what happens when you add to
coordinate objects you just add the X
values you just add the Y values do you
add them both together do you do
whatever you'd like to do and then you
document what you've decided so let's
create a fraction object okay so we've
looked at a coordinate we've saw sort of
a higher level car object let's look at
a fraction object fraction object is
going to be is going to represent a
number that's going to be a numerator
/ a denominator okay
so that's going to be a fraction object
so the way I've decided to internally
represent a fraction object is with two
numbers and I've decided that I will not
let them be floats they have to be
integers
hence the assert over here
so inside the anit I've decided I'm
going to represent the two numbers with
sorry I'm going to represent my fraction
with two numbers one for the numerator
and one for the denominator so when I
create a fraction object I'm going to
pass in a numerator and a denominator
and a particular instance is going to
have self numerator and self denominator
as its data attributes and I'm assigning
those to be whatever's passed into my in
it since I plan on debugging this this
code maybe possibly sometime in the
future I'm also including an STR method
and the STR method is going to print a
nice you know a nice-looking a string
that's going to represent the numerator
and then a slash and then the
denominator and then I've also
implemented some other special methods
how do I add two fractions how do I
subtract two FLAC fractions and how do I
convert a fraction to a float okay the
add and subtract are almost the same so
let's look at the add for the moment how
do we add two fractions right we're
going to take self which is the which is
the instance of an object that I want to
do the add operation on and we're going
to take other which is the other
instance of an object that I want to do
the operation on so the addition and I'm
going to figure out the new top so the
new top of the of the resulting fraction
so it's the it's my numerator multiplied
by the other denominator plus my
denominator multiplied by the other
numerator and then divided by the
multiplication of the two denominators
so the top is going to be that the
bottom is going to be that notice that
we're using self dot right once again
we're trying to access the data
attributes of each different instance
right of myself and the other object
that I'm working with
so that's why I have to do self dot here
once I figure out the top and the bottom
of the Edition I'm going to return and
here notice I'm returning a fraction
object okay it's not a number it's not a
float it's not an integer it's a new
object that is of the exact same type as
the class that I'm implementing okay so
as as it's the same type of object then
on the return value I can do all of the
exact same operations that I can do on a
regular fraction object okay sub is
going to be the same I'm returning a
fraction object float is just going to
do the division for me so it's going to
take the numerator and then divide it by
the denominator just just divide the
numbers and then I'm divide defining
here my own function my own method
called inverse and this is just going to
take the inverse of the instance I'm
calling this method on and so it's going
to also return a new fraction object
that just has the denominator as the top
part and the numerator as the bottom
part so then we have some code here so
that's how that's how I implement my
fraction object so now let's use it and
see what it gives us a is equal to
fraction 1/4 this is going to be
[Music]
this is going to be one over for for a
and B is going to be three over four
when I do C notice I'm using the plus
operator between two fraction objects
right and B are fraction objects so
Python is going to say okay is there an
underscore underscore ad underscore
underscore method implemented it is and
it's just going to do whatever is inside
here so it's going to say self done
numerator plus other denominator it's
going to calculate the top and the
bottom it's going to turn a new fraction
object so this is going to be 4 plus 4
divided by I'm sorry
four plus 12 divided by 16 okay and 16
over 16 so see as a fraction object is
going to be 16 for the numerator and 16
for the denominator right because it's a
fraction object if I print C it should
print 16 over 16 so we can even run it
so it prints 16 over 16 if I print float
C so this special method float here is
going to say is there a method that
converts a fraction to a float and there
is it's this one implemented right here
so it's just going to divide the two
numbers top and bottom which gives me 1
so it's this one here and here notice
I'm calling I'm doing the exact same
method call except I'm doing it the
other way where you type in the name of
the method the name of the class name of
the method and then what you're calling
it on and this gives the exact same
value here 1.0 and then here i'm calling
the method inverse on object b which is
going to invert 3 over 4 to be 4 over 3
and then i'm converting it to a float
and then i'm printing the value so it
gives me 1 point 3 3 so take a look at
this take a look at this code in more
detail and and see if you can trace
through all of those different things
and see if you can also write your own
new fraction objects ok so last slide
power of object-oriented programming is
that you can bundle together objects
that have the exact same type and all of
these objects you know are going to have
the same data representation and the
same methods that you can do on them and
ultimately you're going to be building
these layers of abstractions you're
going to be building on a basic object
type in Python you're going to be you're
going to have integer objects float
objects on top of those you can create
lists dictionaries and on top of those
you can even create your own object
types as we saw in your
in this lecture today